you're with someone else on your leads
thank you for coming back to my youtube
channel you know what on this video I
wanted to give you a little like case
analysis to you whether to work out
whether you gonna do a deal or not so I
am in my kitchen in fact this is my baby
boy he's one you turn one today this is
how I stare Alastair has just he's just
finished running a crash course how did
he go
dude we met two years ago he was a
skeptical Scotsman now he's making
between 40 and 50,000 pounds per month
is that is that true my friend yeah but
where are we where we going now place
there we go don't you burn to view some
houses so we're gonna be in houses
tomorrow and Burnley this is Amelia
Amelia is my manager she took him to
Africa with me absolutely killed it
anyway so I want to talk to you about
when you're given properties we're gonna
be doing loads of houses tomorrow how do
you know whether to go ahead of a deal
or not here's what I'll say do a best
case worst case like most likely case
scenario what's the best case what's the
worst case what's the most likely case
work out the return on investment use
your formulas not your feelings and also
always have an exit strategy so if we're
looking to HMOs look I'm gonna I'm going
to always say well what would happen if
this doesn't work as a hmm maybe what
would be the figures if it was a single
that if I'm planning on buying it to do
it up and then to refinance and put my
money out I'll say well what would
happen if this gets down valued you know
what's the worst case scenario always
have an exit strategy listen guys if you
are serious about property and you have
not been to the property investors crash
course I just wanted to show you some
stories and share some things that some
people have said that have come to the
crash course and people come from all
over the world to the crash courses is
two days it's free on the house so watch
this story check it out and I'm gonna
leave a link in the description as well
if you like these videos I fire videos
every single day if you like the videos
some
the like button and subscribe watch
these stories stay tuned and I hope to
see you there real soon as well so my
name is Michael I'm from Surrey I come
here today to the property investment
seminar to learn a bit more about 4p
investments and HMOs I recently done a
seminar with the Rich Dad Poor Dad and
it was kind of like a taster session so
it kind of opened up my mind to property
investment and actually met somebody on
the day that actually mentioned Samuel
and said I should go into YouTube check
out what he's either and teaching and so
forth so I went onto there I saw a lot
of videos that kind of opened up my mind
more about property investments HMOs
leasing properties buying properties
refurbishing them and refinancing it
refinancing them but the energy in here
is something to learn like the first
gentleman who was he was leading a
seminar energy was wicked I was waiting
to see Samuel now get a bit more
knowledge about everything that I've
come here for and yet hopefully gold go
back today with a more broader mindset
of how to how to take my matches into
place today is the second day when I
went home yesterday I couldn't even
sleep I got home very late I just wanted
to get on the internet and just get
everything that geffen going that tested
my knowledge of what I learned from from
the day's work I've done and yeah this
feel very empowered like I feel like I
do I feel like mentally I'm rich already
even though I haven't done any finger in
it and made it and sourced any bills or
anything but in my head I can feel
I've really made bills in my head I'm
already working towards making bills I
know this fingers absolutely flat amazed
and everyone that I've spoken to you
today feels the same way everyone knows
that they can do it and I think everyone
is willing to network with each other
and connect with each other as well so
it's absolutely brilliant today I woke
up 6 a.m. in the morning absolutely
jumped out of my bed this happy and
willing to come to this to this seminar
today was really about that just getting
everything in place that finances and
stuff just putting everything in check
that that your back state national
income expenditures and so forth just to
get the ball rolling so we know exactly
where we're going to be in what time and
if we're going to be in I feel like a
lot of people helped Alice there's been
absolutely wonderful all the guest
speakers also been help me then witness
helped me out as well and that's for
that everyone is connecting with each
other everyone's giving each other some
feedback or what they can do what
they've been doing what they've taken
from it so I think every one of the
collective is benefited from this from
the seminar today the next step so
that's getting the ball rolling so cool
it's like looking for investors dear my
due diligence about certain areas where
I know I can use for Haiti or moles and
I think that's good because when I first
come here
I already had one kind of strategy
that's working towards which was a
buy-to-let now I know three other
strategies I think it is amazing because
it's good to know what areas what what
strategies will work out best in certain
areas so I think with this knowledge
here you can map this capitalise on any
kind of pocket again
[Music]
[Music]